we got this story from you today get
ready to spend more at the grocery store
food price is expected to soar
usda so here's the thing on top of the
economy being in absolute shambles and
people being more panicked about their
ability to access food for the first
time than they've ever been in our
lifetimes this complete disaster uh
the democrats decide you know what on
top of this you know what we need
politically we need to defend grooming
yeah i feel like no no no no no they're
like how do we get people to stop
talking about the fact they can't buy
food defend something unconscionable
you're right they should be focusing on
sustained local food growth like for as
a human it should be like a human thing
that the american government should be
supporting a movement to teach people
how to locally grow their own food we
have we have uh pawpaw season out here
so end of september october there is so
much pawpaw that it's just rotting
everywhere and it's paw paw it's like if
you took a banana a mango an avocado and
mix it all together so it's this like
round green fruit that grows it's
apparently hard to cultivate because
only like beetles and flies pollinate
the flowers
but they're they're everywhere so i was
really excited to try it for the first
time it tastes like a banana avocado
mango you just mixed together so you can
make bread with it you can it's it's
it's all over the place i just i want to
point out man how amazing it is when
you're not in a city because this is
something i think city people don't
realize because i didn't realize it and
all the country people are sitting back
with that straw in their mouth laughing
because they're like yeah there's food
everywhere so i go outside there's
chives we take the chives it makes our
food taste good then we have the berry
season where there's blackberries and
wine berries everywhere you go outside
for 10 minutes and you've got like two
pounds of fresh berries and it's amazing
you do everything with it it's just
delicious obviously you need more than
that but it's just it's crazy growing up
growing up in a city and not realizing
you can just eat stuff outside
it's just nuts people in cities aren't
able to do this
and also people in cities unfortunately
don't know where their food comes from
and i think this is why we have folks
who unfortunately think that a small
garden like that can sustain their city
or make a significant dent here
there was a hilarious article it was it
was actually a letter to the editor and
i've quoted it here before on the show
but somebody basically
wrote to their newspaper saying that it
was offensive that they printed an
article which discussed hunting because
people should just be getting their food
from the grocery store where no animals
are harmed
or i've mentioned how i got an argument
with a guy during uh the primaries when
i was talking about
with with you know how ubi would disrupt
the economy and with the shortages
eventually there's not going to be any
milk at the grocery store and some guy
was like what do you mean you just go to
the grocery store to get the milk it's
just there
and then i was like you realize it's
bottled and sent there right it's like
it's just at the grocery store what do
you mean
well then there's no these people
genuinely don't realize magic no they're
dumb well the milk the dairy is
harvested it's set to various processing
plants for a variety of things cream
half and half sour cream yogurt milk all
the stuff it has to get separated out
right homogenization process then it
goes to bottling and packaging plants
then it goes to like warehouse
distribution then it goes to stores yeah
well and also i mean people
are gonna point to russia the political
leaders are obviously the main reason
this is happening is because they
decided to shut down the supply chain
back in 2020 there were instances where
there were certain foods that we had
shortages of even though that particular
food didn't have a hiccup in its
production or quite as much of a hiccup
to lead to the proportional shortage
that we were seeing because the
government even though they declared
food production to be essential declared
the production of items that were
required for the packaging of that food
to be non-essential so the food was
produced but it could just never get to
the grocery store oh my gosh
yeah i've been working with this company
called eden growth systems that's
developing they have some nasa
technology and you can basically grow
indoors and the idea is four of these
towers can sustain one person
indefinitely but i don't know if a if a
capitalist movement like buy this
product i'm about to start using it so
i'm really excited to see the value like
you can grow eggplants and stuff um you
you've got to have your own guard at the
very least you know
when i lived in new york there was no
way to have a garden it was impossible i
could have a garden box with maybe one
plant and maybe have like a tomato but
that's that's that's that's nothing
that's why i'm like you know what people
who live in the cities you do your thing
look at this story we got from raw story
iowa's bird flu death toll tops 13
million
this is there's a pandemic happening
among chickens but it means eggs will be
more expensive it means chicken meat's
gonna be harder to come by and we
already saw the chicken wing shortage
during the pandemic likely likely to
happen again especially with the global
food shortages that are coming so i
brought up stem cell meat i believe that
we're headed towards a feature where we
don't eat farm animals like this that's
going to be really really good there's
no fat curious
about this so obviously you know we have
a picture of a chicken here which
creates the mental connection that the
birds dying from this are livestock but
how are they getting this 13 million
number is it chickens that are dying is
it is it's chickens that are dying
it's it's i believe specifically okay
okay
poultry uh poultry flocks in iowa this
has been big news so we've actually we
we've been warned just to make sure we
quarantine any chickens we get outside
because we we have our chickens we have
like 50 now because we bred a whole
bunch and so we were told by a breeder
like any chickens you get keep them
separated for 30 days which is kind of a
normal thing because you don't want to
spread diseases or whatever but right
now it's fairly serious
we got chickens
chickens lay eggs all the time it's
fantastic we got too many eggs too many
we had in like one week we had 74 eggs
i don't even know we just made a whole
bunch of these great deviled eggs so
yeah yeah those are awesome oh man yeah
that was great i gotta start eating my
yeah i wonder what percentage this is of
the the total livestock of chickens that
we have in the country it's just a lot
no i mean i agree it's frightening
i'm just saying it's it's things like
this that are all kind of happening
around the same time that are like you
pay attention to the stuff
uh
you know in 2015 a deadly bird flu
outbreak resulted in 32 million birds in
i would uh getting cold
so they say iowa's affected birds this
year account for 59
of the country's current 22.4 million
total according to the u.s department of
agriculture and data hey you know what
so just about 60 of our chickens this is
also an indication of the danger of
centralized farming when you have one
yes buy chickens yeah build your own
chicken city and have them far away from
each other so that if one little batch
gets ill that's okay well you just keep
trying
chickens into social
they might need our help you should see
the way they call these chickens if
you've never seen a video of them
calling chickens it's freaking horrific
i'm not gonna even talk about it on on
air because it's so disturbing uh but it
involves suffocation so i guess i did
talk about it on air i guess so i just
feel for these animals man look in their
eyes they are not npcs there's something
going on there humans eat meat i get it
and i'm not saying we shouldn't but
there are other ways to derive your meat
than
growing and killing something for it i
know that's been the way that we've been
doing it for for
ever i think that's just like naivety
bro
i don't i'm not making it just it's not
like it's not a fantasy there's
technology backing it up i i always i
always like the way the native americans
would go about it you know you'd kill
the animal and then you would basically
like have some sort of prayer of like
what you are getting from this creature
that you whose life you've taken like
there's like respect to life but
recognizing that we humans we survive
and we eat meat and i'm sorry man i
genui i think humans eat meat that's it
like there's a lot of people who are
like humans who actually don't eat meat
i think it was mostly fish but humans
eat meat yeah it's less about the meat
more about the suffering and the the
sickness that comes from factory farm
that i'm concerned and i i will say this
there is something about
you know
growing cultivating or even hunting your
own food i've you know i don't do it
often but i have gone hunting and when
you see the cost when you actually kill
an animal in order to get food from it
you don't waste it
you're way less likely to waste food we
waste food all the time because we just
go to the grocery store and get it and
we don't even have to consider the fact
that an animal died for it but you
understand inherently there's there's
this lack of gratitude there's this
disrespect in wasting food that most
people never acknowledge
thank you when we go out to eat
so much food gets wasted and what do you
do because i'm not talking about like
you order a steak and half of it you're
just like i'm not eating half that steak
ever again i mean like a couple bites
here and there and that that really
really adds up
if we were actually in like a famine
situation nothing would be wasted you'd
be you'd be you'd be boiling tree bark
if you were starving well i mean it's
just like a different i mean it would
completely change the culture right like
you read about like people who grew up
in the great depression just hoarding
like just and not just food right stuff
uh because it's like well you never know
how you might need to use this and that
was much more common when i was 18
i was hanging out with my grandpa
and i was i made a peanut butter jelly
sandwich with his bread and then i saw
there was mold on the bread and then i
was like ah i'm not gonna eat it and
he's like why not and i was like there's
mold on he goes you know during the
depression and then he grabs it and he
just like just eats the whole thing and
i was like you can at least take the
mold off yeah he didn't care you get
sick from that man i don't know what
kind of mold was it do you remember it
was blue i don't know blue mold those
black molds very dangerous blue green
yellow i think penicillin's white mold
yeah but mold's still bad don't want to
eat it but uh you know his point was
like during the during the depression
they would eat whatever they could
you eat what you can get
we
you know i hear stories about the
depression i don't think we've seen
anything like that no matter how bad
things have gotten no no i mean
it's hard it's i it's doubtful that we
would
honestly like there's there's a level of
uh
i don't know just like how developed our
economy is it's really hard to imagine
something i mean we forget how
relatively undeveloped things were in
that period in large portions of the
country
um people need to realize the these
systems can be knocked down very easily
yeah i mean you mean you can screw them
up for a longer period i don't know i
guess i'm more of an optimist on than
you guys on that front like i just you
know you read about what things were
really like in the great depression and
not just and not just i'm talking about
like rural areas like rural
electrification was still like not
really a thing you know um you know i
think a really good book if anybody
wants to read about this is actually the
first series in the series of
biographies of lyndon johnson because
lyndon johnson grew up in hill country
texas in like poor and it was poor i
mean thir you know what we would
consider like worse than poverty poor
then
um and you realize how far things have
come like in rural areas especially in
terms of like in basic infrastructure
clean water clean water is a huge part
of it south america you could see i went
down there and i was helping clean the
amazon out and we're with these tribes
this one truck or one of early tribes
they're just in bailin and iquitos and
they didn't know that poop water was bad
for you so they'd defecate in the water
and then drink it and they'd distended
stomachs and like
not only was the education lacking so
yes clean water but also education we
need maintain access to at least maybe
electricity and internet so that we can
continue to
educate kids properly i think maybe um
yeah
maybe we need some kind of uh um a way
to just get things to to to go back to
baseline
so that we can kind of figure out how
much food people really yeah you're
talking about like a recess yeah that's
a great reset
resetting of the whole global system
really be great if nobody owned anything
for that i would be happy much easier to
move things around you should be happy
yeah i'd be happy yeah you could spin up
a corporation maybe that surrounds
yourself that's surrounded around that
idea maybe we can do some kind of
organization about like global economics
have like a forum i was just a year
ago oh my goodness yes
forum of economic on economics a world
foreign economics the world
that's a great idea
i think you are on to something i'm
rolling
around at 20. roll that dollar
roll the 20 dice i got a 59.
that's one of the worst numbers but
boring numbers that could have rolled
right there i wanna i wanna make sure
that uh you know we saw shortages we saw
prices increase
i've been going to the grocery store and
the prices have definitely been going
way up consistently very quickly and so
my concern is
are we seeing from the media and the
bite administration fear-mongering i
don't know why they would want to do
that right now considering elections are
coming up
are people experiencing normalcy bias
and optimism bias meaning it can't
happen or something like that will never
happen
right the optimism bias is like no that
couldn't happen and normalcy is like
well that's never happened so
everything's going to stay the same and
i'm not going to worry about it
or are we going to see something
dramatic like we've not seen in a long
time like ground war in europe
fertilizer shortages
i think
at the very least we should expect to
see
africa
starvation is going to get nuts i'm glad
that biden said the word famine because
it's people like my parents that need to
hear it from the authority to really
start taking it seriously
maybe they'll buy extra beans or
something we need peace in russia and
ukraine geez i don't know like that
should there's a lot of people who want
to keep the war going to drain russia as
though it's like a cold war and we need
to do that you know we need to just
strain them out in afghanistan right no
no no we need peace we want peace
between russia yeah
take it when you can get it because in a
war if something changes with the
leadership one day there's no that
that's off the table now like if some
psycho not that putin's not i'm not
saying he's a psycho some real genuine
cycle like a putin gets assassinated and
some crazy oligarch gets a hold you may
never see an option for peace again i
think i think you know
once we have the piece everyone should
just not own anything and be happy yeah
i would say so i mean that yeah
absolutely
then there's like someone who tuned into
the show for the first time like
i hear a lot of good things about this
tim pool guy
i don't want to watch this show ever
again
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there